US.
A BIG STORY ON THE DEMOCRATS AND
IMMIGRATION.
A SWAMP WATCH ON HOW TOYS "R" US
WAS TREATED BY ELITIST FATCATS
THAT YOU DON'T WANT TO MISS.
FIRST, LAST WEEK WE TALKED ABOUT
THE ESTABLISHMENT REACTION OF
PRESIDENT TRUMPS EUROPEAN TRIP,
AND POINTED OUT ALL WHY THEY
PONTIFICATED ABOUT THIS.
I WASN'T WRONG.
THIS IS PART TWO.
LIKE OTHERS, EVEN ON THIS
THIS IS PERSONAL FOR ME.
MY PARENTS ARE HUNGARIAN.
COMMUNIST.
PRESIDENT TRUMPS TREATMENT OF
HIM IN PUBLIC IT WOULD BE
CONSIDERED AN INSULT TO BE
DEFINITELY IDIOTIC.
HERE'S WHAT I SET ON MONDAY.
THE PRESIDENT IS TOTALLY WRONG
NOT TO STRONGLY CONDEMNED THE
RUSSIA ATTACK.
JUST WISH ESTABLISHMENTS LIKE
JOHN MCCAIN WHEREAS FIRED UP
OVER THE REGIME THAT ATTACKED US
AND IT'S A MUCH BIGGER THREAT
THAN RUSSIA, IN CHINA.
BUT THE HYSTERICAL OVER THE TOP
OF REACTIONS OF THE ANGER,
ELITES OR EVEN WORSE, THE FBI'S
WERE OUT IN FORCE BY THE LED BY
THE SEVERELY CREEPY, JOHN
BRENNAN.
>> GOOD FOR DAN COATS FOR
AND THOSE WHO ARE GOING TO BE
SILENT IN THIS ADMINISTRATION
ARE COMPLICIT.
THEY NEED TO BE ABLE TO SPEAK
OUT AND A STRONG WAY.
THE FBI, CIA, SIA ANOTHER'S.
TREASONOUS.
IT IS A BETRAYAL OF THE NATION.
HE IS GIVING AID AND COMFORT TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS LITERALLY A
RUSSIAN AGENT.
HERE SENATOR TAMMY DUCKWORTH.
>> REPUBLICANS CANNOT TURN A
BLIND EYE TO KNOW THAT PUTIN HAS
COMPROMISED OUR OFFICER AND
CHIEF.
>> AND TODAY, A DEMOCRATIC
CONGRESSMAN, SOFT MOLTEN.
>> TO THINK IT'S POSSIBLE THE
PRESIDENT IS A RUSSIAN ASSET
WITH OR WITHOUT HIS KNOWLEDGE?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
>> STEVE: THE EXTREMISM OF THE
LEFT PUSHES PEOPLE NOT AWAY FROM
PRESIDENT TRUMP, BUT TOWARDS
HIM.
AFTER THE UNHINGED RUSSIA TALK,
THERE TO IMPORTANT THINGS TO
REMEMBER.
FIRST, PUTIN IS NOT THE ONLY
DICTATOR THREATENING AMERICA.
CHINA'S PRESIDENT IS MUCH MORE
EVIL AND MUCH BIGGER THREAT.
CHINA HAS BEEN MEDDLING IN OUR
DEMOCRACY FOR YEARS.
THEY'RE CORRUPTED BY CHINESE
CASH.
WE WILL SHOW YOU THIS IN A SWAMP
WATCH ON NEXT SUNDAY.
SECONDLY, WERE THE ONES WHO MADE
HER DEMOCRATIC PROTESTANT
VULNERABLE TO FOREIGN ATTACKS BY
BUYING INTO THE IDEA THAT
TALKING ABOUT HOW THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT IS TRYING TO PROTECT
THE 22 MIDTERM ELECTIONS.
>> PUBLIC ATTRIBUTION
>> PUBLIC ATTRIBUTION TO HELP
COUNTER OR MITIGATE THE HARM
CALLED BY SPONSORED INFORMATION.
WHEN PEOPLE ARE WHERE THEY CAN
MAKE BETTER INFORMED DECISIONS.
WE HELP TECHNOLOGY COMPANIES TO
COUNTER COVERT EFFORTS.
THE FBI WORKS WITH PARTNERS TO
INFRASTRUCTURE AND DEVELOP THEIR
ONLINE PRESENCE.
>> WHAT AN IDIOT.
THE DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL, THE
MORE WE RELY ON BIG, CENTRALIZED
TECHNOLOGY, MORE FRAGILE AND
VULNERABLE WE ARE.
IF YOU WANT TO MAKE THE ELECTION
SECURE GO BACK TO PEOPLE MARKING
THEIR BALLOTS WITH A PENCIL AND
PAPER AND HUMAN BEINGS COUNTING
IDIOT'S RULING CLASS HAVE BEEN
WHAT A BUNCH OF IDIOTS.